I the allies that we read from
assignment to assignment and part two,
because we read in a very selective way.
I know that a lot of gaps in
the, in the, in our readings,
I never really have tried to
share with you the idea that,
that he's align and now that they've line
their conceptual line running through
the poem, the candles,
I looked discreet units,
poetic units,
uh,
without much relationship worthy.
The links are to be found symmetrically
maybe with Qantas fall apart from the
cancers that we're, we, we,
we are reading. I think that
there is a continuity, uh,
going through or through many
of them and there is no data.
For instance,
between the cantos 15,
16 and 17 of paradise we read
last time and Kansas of 17,
18 and 19.
That is actually a thematic expansion of
some of the issues that Dante racers in
the heaven of Mars, um, to begin with.
Cancer 77, 18, uh,
Dante in Canto 18 is still in the having
of marsh and he meets and he lists,
I know that I did not, the number does
not appear in your, in your syllabus,
but you know, uh, just bear with me
so that I can, I can, uh, go home.
We decide this. And he just
lists the number of, uh,
a warrior souls who are Wa figures,
heroic figures, the heroic lives, uh,
very much like catcher Weda himself who
appears is one of the blessed from lines
forward.
In following of Canto 18,
he mentions he sees and he mentioned,
uh,
Joshua Biblical figures,
Joshua and Judah Maccabee years.
And then he goes on a
mentoring medieval figures. Uh,
Charlemagne. There's clearly
he's justifying retrospectively,
uh,
the whole issue of the Crusades to
which catch a weeder took part in,
which can really be brought
back to Charlotte mains, uh,
experience in France and in
Spain against them. Awesome.
So he mentions it lists a
Charlemagne and of course his power.
Then the great,
the so called the Achilles like
invulnerable Roland who however dies at
[inaudible],
which is a the side of the war
between Muslims and Christians.
And he dies because of the Hubris
that characterizes his wife,
uh, the Hubris of not wanting to blow, uh,
the bugle that it would be
heard by Charlemagne and
Charlemagne could have come
to his rescue,
as I have probably said before,
that became in the western imagination
and most traumatic experience,
a traumatic experience
because it showed the, uh,
that the myth of invincibility
of the Christian,
of Christian real Christian Europe
was simply that an illusion,
uh, to be turned into rubble
by the invading of Victoria Sa,
uh,
Christian armies.
And then he goes on mentioning the
figures of the second crusade, uh,
1109, the Godfrey of Bujo. Uh, and, uh,
I figure a Norman who defeated
actually that Muslims in Sicily,
uh,
the discard Robert this word and
brought about in the early 19th century,
in the late ninth century, has about 75
years. The Muslims were there. The, the,
the expulsion of the Muslims from,
from Sicily.
Uh,
so we,
we clear thematic thread
between the previous cancers.
And this can too is the question
of what is a heroic life.
And the heroic life can even involve a
defeat as in the case of Roland it in
price, however heroic life
clearly low that he said,
typology that runs from
Joshua's defeat of uh,
and, and seizure of the, of
Jericho. You know, this is
the great, the, the, the, the,
the epic Biblical story to
whiskered contemporary history,
almost contemporary history for,
for Dante, it implies really,
uh, uh, division. It
implies a heroic life,
which is the, they, the,
the power to establish
a and live for a cause,
which is going to be
for Dante to just coast.
But it's a cost that brings
about divisions. So it's not, uh,
a heroic figure is not necessarily a
figure that would unify a and cut across,
uh, barriers and, and
individuals on the contrary.
But Dante's indicating
that it's supposed to, the,
there is a possible
heroic life on, to, uh,
a giving of oneself to a cause
much larger than consults.
We could just leave it at that. Okay.
Uh, and we'll come back to this, uh,
this issue in a moment. What I would
stress and in, in, in a few minutes,
what would stress though
about this particular, um,
particular scene is that Dante
is really a way of divisions,
a Whir of divisions, aware of
the need even to separate, uh,
what is mine from what is not mine,
what is hours from [inaudible]. So it's,
it would seem, he seems,
will be perpetuating
a myth that's, uh, uh,
that or an idea that some might find it
objectionable that indeed the separation
is dangerous and it's
in itself caused by war.
And the cause of wars,
you know, this is the,
the objection to this, uh, this problem.
It's not the only time that Dante
is a establishing divisions.
When, when I've been talking, uh, uh,
over the past few weeks
about, for instance, uh,
divisions and boundaries that Dante
establishes even when talking about
continents, you remember that,
uh, in Canto six of paradise,
uh, when there's the story of
the Eagle of the Roman Empire,
a dentist goes on talking
about the periphery of Europe
where the Justinian and
the bird of the empire had
Nestle's, uh, the east,
the eastern part of the empire
that was the periphery of Europe.
And we have been talking about
the, the whole, uh, how in, in,
in Canto 12 of,
uh,
of paradise meeting, uh, Dominic, uh, uh,
Saint Dominic Dante talks
about the western part of
Europe and goes out of their
way to mention this already.
So they are always divisions.
There are always barriers.
He seems to believe that
Rome and the history of Rome,
uh,
really escapes this logic of
separation and then affect this.
I know that I mentioned to you in
a Monarchia that political tract,
he writes,
he fast stress the fact that nes
is really enrollment and not,
for instance, he cannot really
be thought of as a nation,
which he was Norgen he be
thought of as a European.
And he stresses the fact
that he has a kind of, some,
there's a sort of a
universalizing history in him,
a universalizing impulse in the measure
in which he may read three women from
three different continents
craves from Asia,
Dido from Africa, and Levenia from, uh,
from Europe. So he does distinguish
between a kind of, sort of, uh,
the history that transcends barriers,
but also an idea which is really
heroic here of a over history,
that manager,
what keeps barriers that this,
that these are people who fought at
the Crusades. This is the, the, the,
the many of them. So certainly not
Joshua and Judah Maccabee use, but, uh,
Charlemagne nor the Crusades, but against
them. I was on a Roland, uh, but, uh,
Godfrey of your and so on.
And we'll see what the
consequences of this may be.
Now another conceptual thread. I'm,
I'm really going around two or three.
Uh, I think I'm keeping two,
three themes in my head now,
another conceptual threads
between 17, uh, and uh,
and the,
and the remaining
part of a 18, 19, and, uh, 18, 19 and 20,
which is the heaven of Jupiter,
uh,
is the question of a very abstract
question. I've done tasks.
What is a place?
And that was the underlying
problem in [inaudible] 15, 16,
and 17 and 15,
90 twice to determine whether his history
could be reduced to the boundaries of
his own native town and decides that
that was no longer possible for him to
conceive. Uh, the famous chronicles, he,
he tries to figure out, uh, uh,
where exactly he can be in the history of,
uh,
in the midst of Florence himself.
It's a itself and decides
that he is an exile.
That was the final prophecy of culture.
Weeder.
Exile is a word that it
means it's Latin word, uh,
in Italian and or in English it
comes to being out of one's own soil.
That's what the meaning is.
So that in the Middle Ages,
they never really thought of.
Exilis is just a spiritual condition.
There's to say, I feel
this located, I am, uh, my,
my personal existential predicament.
Is that a feeling up,
I'm out of it,
that I don't belong or that kind of,
that was not the
conventional understanding.
Dante changes this meaning of exile in
making it into a spiritual condition.
It's the condition of,
it's the precondition for his
writing poetry to begin with.
So that poetry and exile
seem to be, uh, going, uh,
going to here in 18, the real issue
that he raises is what is it place?
Okay, I am an exile. I do not belong
anywhere. Uh, what is it, what, what,
how do we understand here? And
how do we understand their, uh,
what does it mean? What are these terms?
What, what, what? Um, at any rate,
so he starts and he enters now and two
can talk with the remaining part of the
Ken to 18.
He enters into the heaven of
Jupiter having a white light,
which he links with geometry.
You know what a geometry is a science,
very complex science.
It encompasses what it means is
the measurement of the earth.
Uh, it's the whole worth that you
want can measure with medieval,
medieval George's. It means, it implies
the presence of perspective within it.
Uh,
with the idea that a geometry is what
regulates the idea of space and the,
the, uh, arrangement of space. It,
it implies altimetry,
it implies the measurement
of the depth and so on. Uh,
it is,
as you know,
traditionally linked to ethics.
It's has a profound intimate linkage with
ethics because for the simple reason,
well, uh, when done to discuss this
justice for instance, in Cantos,
uh, in, in, in Fab, no, he distinguishes
between a distributive justice.
You remember in federal seven,
the,
the goddess for tuna who
manages to distribute a,
with some idea of him of,
of impenetrable or Colt equity,
a cold justice,
the goods of the earth,
or she's blind folded and uh,
uh,
moves the wheel around the, so that can
be some kind of a uniform. If you are up,
you're not going to be up all the
time, you may be down, et cetera.
And if you are down, you
eventually, if you are on the
shift, the curve of fortune,
you are going to be up.
It's a sort of, uh, uh,
other theoretical notion
of equity. You know, if you
have, sometimes you have five,
then you lose three and you get to
have to whoever has one we'll get to et
cetera. The other form of justice
was also geometric justice,
which tend to describes in the so called
rule of the counterpart counter passion
in the country pass. So in fair, no, 28,
when he has to establish the relationship
between crime and punishment,
it could not be an even
one, you know, one and one.
You cannot park someone's high
because someone has pluck your eye.
That's not necessarily justice.
You cannot cut someone's arm off because
you have a perpetrated that crime or
kill be killed because he
has to have been killed.
There should be some kind of
proportionality, uh, the arguments.
So the idea is the geometry is
always part geometry. In fact, uh,
uh, uh, the, the is, is, uh, is,
is related to ethics
simply because it's a, uh,
it's extension always implies a point,
which is the beginning of a geometric
reflection always implies the
existence of other points.
It establishes relations. Therefore,
that's a, that's the language. So,
or in this candle, Dante
discusses primarily justice. Okay?
What is justice?
That's the idea that runs through this.
The other thing that you have
to be as you read this cantors,
and I hope you read them with care,
um,
and I will not say much
about it, is that, uh, uh,
he deployed Dante deploys
the language of geometry.
Now,
you know that this is a technique of his,
if he were dealing with the arithmetic,
he, we'll do a music who will do that.
But I just want to give you a few,
a few words,
samples of, uh, of this.
Uh, uh, this, this is yours.
For instance, uh, uh, just
letting me open here in, uh, uh,
the notion of a god, the
geometer for the, uh,
he will go on, uh, uh, talking,
for instance, this is in, uh, uh,
can tall, uh, 19, uh,
uh, Canto 19, um,
anywhere really like [inaudible] look
at this, uh, uh, the primer will,
which is self good from itself.
The supreme good neighbor was moved,
whatever a with it is in that measure,
just the language of measure,
no created good draws it to itself,
but rain fourth ray,
which in Italian is both radius.
It's the ray of sunlight,
but also the radius of a circle are,
creates a good as the stoke circles.
There it goes. Even the, the,
the various shapes,
circles over the nest.
And then a little bit further down
wheeling it, sank then spoke cetera.
Wheeling again,
circular,
a circular motion. And, uh, and,
and, and this continues, a literary
continues throughout the, I want to,
to find for you the image of, um, uh, the,
uh, the image of, uh, of, of,
of the compacts that, uh, I
thought it was in Canton 19. I,
it's not. So I, we'll, we'll
get to that. We'll find it.
So the number of this, uh, uh,
this, uh, uh, geometrical terms. However,
the most important thing here in Kendall
19 is that as soon as he enters the
heaven of geometry,
now we encounter in the,
I'm sorry,
in Canto 18, he, we, we,
we come across a play,
a divine spectacle. It's,
it's, it's all 12. Uh,
uh,
the heavens are a sacred theater where
God will go on speaking to human beings
by using to us on earth by,
uh,
by using the souls of the
blessed. This is, uh, um,
uh, this is the, the,
the passage I saw lion canto 18,
nine, seven and following us.
So in the torch of Jove,
the sparkling of love,
that was their trays out.
Our speech to my eyes.
And this birds reason from a river
bank is if rejoicing together over the
pasture make of themselves
now around flock.
That's a geometric image for you.
Now another shape.
So within the lightly lights,
holy creatures,
we're singing is the fluid
made themselves in the figure,
the figures they formed.
Now d now I know l first singing,
they moved to their own notes,
then becoming one of these shapes that
posts for a rental and were silent.
Um, within the, the,
the having a majority,
even the letters of the alphabet,
Joe Geometrical lines,
the same circle of the, uh, the two, uh,
the perpendicular line of the l and
the perpendicular line of the eye.
They'll do. We are, we are,
we really discover that the beauty of
geometry underlies the rigor of the
alphabet,
so to speak about more importantly,
we discovered that this souls that
disposed themselves in letters. I really,
uh, the way, God's way of
speaking to us that the language,
Dante, that God uses is the
language of human beings.
We are the syllabus.
We are the letters disposed
in order to convey this, uh,
this whatever God's message may be,
the show themselves then in five
times seven vowels and consonants.
And I noted them severely and what they
seem to me to mean, the league eater,
you stitch them, they spill
out, align, taken from the book.
A verse from, uh, the book
of Wisdom, love, justice,
delegating [inaudible]. You
who Josh, who judge the Earth.
That's another reference to the actual
ultimate measurement of geometry.
The earth. I just, that's the meaning of a
geometry, the measuring of the earth. So,
uh, uh, geography in a
certain way is part of, uh,
the world of geometry. Then, then Dante
goes on describing a metamorphosis,
how on the m of the fifth word,
they kept the oldest of the Jupiter same,
their silver pricked up with gold and
that's what the hot lights descend on the
very summit of the M and
settle there singing,
I think of the good that
draws them to itself.
Then as with burning logs are struck,
rise in numerable sparks from which the
foolish are accustomed to make auguries.
So more than a thousand lights appeared
to rise again from there and to mount
some, uh, some much, some literal,
this hundred kindle them appointed when
each ad set on that's place, et cetera.
Uh, I know that some of you are
working on the aesthetics of collars.
I would point out the scene to you
and the complications of color,
the white of Jupiter,
the gold of the letters,
the red of the flames. Ah,
there is a kind of chromatic,
chromatic deployment,
dramatic elements within this,
uh, this grand spectacle, uh,
Dante's indicating directly and
indirectly they this chromatic, uh,
uh, symbolism. So this is
what we are, what, what,
what w the way the heavens
speak to us on earth and to the,
and those and the rulers of the earth.
Uh,
and then Dante goes on
in the next Canto 19,
uh,
wondering what is this idea of justice?
What does it mean? Um, oh,
he last Canto 19
clients 28.
I know where the doe,
the divine justice is mirrored
in another room of heaven.
Yours apprehends it without a veil,
you know,
with that intent has been prepared to
listen. You know, what is that doubt,
which is so old. If a
fast in me, he's hungry,
Dante's hungry to know what divine
justice is and what are we here is,
uh, uh, the faculty, etc. The, uh, the,
the bird or the ego goes on saying
he that turned his commpass.
That's God as the geometer
an image that clearly yet
goes to biblical texts.
One is of job 38,
the famous passage,
some of you may know Dante
terms with repeatedly,
where were you when I drew
the boundaries of the earth?
Oh, that's the geometrical, they,
they the, the matrix, so to speak. Uh,
I mean it was the age
of, of, uh, of, uh, this,
uh,
metaphor of a god,
the geometer and the other one
is in the book of Wisdom. Uh,
um, the, the, that goes
on talking about, uh, uh,
I was there with him and that was his
delight when he was drawing the circle
around.
The deep that's in the book was a two,
two biblical passages
that insists on this, uh,
both a geometric and then
aesthetic it theater.
The idea that to the shapes of the
world are really representations of,
is this perfection of God's geometry.
There are two metaphors. The
dentate goes on, uh, deploying.
But let's see what the substance
of the argument now is.
He then turned this compass. You
know, we understand what he uses,
the word compacts and the image
of the compass that's clear,
not remain in infinite access.
That's to me another
geometrical language though.
The two words are slightly
redundant because access means the,
the uh, the eight something which
is measure less. Ah, AH, the, the,
the language of measure,
the language of, uh, uh,
accounting and the language of
limits is set against this idea of a,
something, not, not finite,
something that escapes the,
the logic of geometry.
Okay.
The logic of measurements and
Infinitech access. In fact,
I find the phrase deliberately
redundance is also an only infinite,
but it's also excessive idea
of the infinite, uh, to drive,
drive the point home.
Um, you, uh, manifest,
could not make his power to be so
impressed on the whole universe.
Even the Word Universe is, uh, as a,
uh, as, as much as the poetic I, uh,
uh,
term we speak of verse in poetry
and that wonder how many of you have ever
wondered whether that's that word come
from, it comes from geometry. Cars
in price, it turning, you know,
you come to the end of the line and you
turn and you draw geometrical figure.
And so that's the universe. It's
one tourney. It's this fear.
You can have a hemispheres,
but the two hemispheres make the universe.
No, these are all as you see, uh, uh,
I hope you enjoy them as I enjoy
them telling you about, uh, uh,
about this and improve this.
The first proud spirits Lucifer.
Now that's geometry of
the soul. Oh, the first,
the first proud spirit who was in the,
you know,
Dante connects pride and geometry
or perspective as we said before.
Um,
the first proud spirit who was in the
highest that was highest of all creatures,
fair and ripe with a
great adjective. Uh, uh,
Lucifer falls and ripe because
grace in price or ripeness,
ripeness, the idea that you are ripe
when you have been touched by grace,
right? And it says, all
one could say using another, referring
to another text, not by dance,
through, uh, through,
not waiting for light.
That's Lucifer from which of this play
that every lesson needs is to scan to a
vessel for the good,
which has no limit and measure.
I'm not going to indicate
that anymore itself by itself.
That's so vision which must needs but
be one of the rays of the mind of which
all things are full cannot by its nature
we have such power that it should not
perceive its origin to be far beyond
though there appears therefore,
and that seems to be the um,
the essence,
the brunt of the argument.
The site that is granted to your
world penetrates within the terminal.
Justice is the eye into the c four.
Though from the shore it sees
the bottom in the open sea.
It does not.
And yet the bottom is there,
but the depth conceals it.
Uh,
the idea that uh,
we can see justice only when we have a
very superficial and we see just to see
the, the, the bottom of the, of
the sea when we are near the shore.
Only when we have a superficial
understanding of do we do we do we see the
bottom.
Otherwise we don't.
God's justice is imponderable
and unfathomable as the
sea floor can be out in,
uh, uh, out of, uh, away from the
shore. There is no light there,
but which comes from the clearance
on and the changes and then done
complicates the issue a little bit.
And he really asks,
where is the justice?
Is Justice Limited to
a place to a continent,
to the economy of Christian Europe?
And how is it related to other places?
We have an ocean of what
nowadays we call our parity.
You must have heard that term. The
other, the idea of the other, uh,
it's uh, in the Middle Ages, by the way,
it was not alien to this
thought of the other. Uh,
I can give you a few titles of uh, um, uh,
Aquinas writing a track against
the errors of the Greeks. That's,
that's the sense of
idleness establishing this,
you say differences or Aquinas
writing is summa against the gentiles.
The pagans. We usually actually where
the philosophers of the time, the, the,
those who do not have access to or exceed
the one to succeed to revelations the,
have an idea of otherness.
And the,
the of another nurse is always that over
acknowledging that particular defense.
I do not see at this point yet any
substantial deviation on the part of Dante
from the myth and the
examples of the heroic life.
The examples of the heroic life are those
who literally established boundaries,
who within those boundaries managed to
live according to the fullness of the
virtuals.
That's a heroic life.
And that's really the boundary
that he establishes. Now, tasks.
What is that boundary?
Okay, I understand that,
that divine justice is impenetrable,
but then he asks this
extraordinary question,
what is a place where is a place?
And so this was a main,
it's born or the Bank
of the Indus line 72.
I think this is the most complex and
the most extraordinary question in the
whole of the divine comedy from,
from the point who have the awareness of,
uh,
let's say I'll tear it.
No,
Maine is born on the Bank of the English
Asia and none is there to speak or read
or write of Christ and all his desires
and doing her good so far as humor.
Regencies without sitting in
life. Who speech, he dies,
I'm baptized.
And without faith,
what is this justice that condemned him?
What is his fault?
If he does not believe? And then, uh,
now who are the other would sit upon the
bench and judge a thousand miles away,
more geometry or mode space,
more distance if is comes to
being not only one of depth.
Now one of huge distances in space
with the site short of a span and the
spending, you know, by the
way, it's a great, you know,
that it's uh, it's, it's uh,
a measurement, a geometric term
too. That's the, that's the span.
The distance that goes from the tip of
the thumb to the tip of the little finger.
Uh, you know, this is technically Italian
Spanish and the English is
span, uh, comes from it.
I should surely for him that
will reason it out with me.
The scripture were not set over you. There
will be abandoned room for questions.
And then he goes on talking,
uh,
as the stalks circle and Dante's clearly
circling over this stuff himself over
this, uh, this issues. And we have, uh,
it turned to Europe,
the whole of Europe and our peers,
the whole of Kendall's,
Nah, it's a hundred and uh,
uh, and, and, and till the end. And
let me just read this passage where,
um, uh, the eagle,
the Romans and well done to goes out of
the way to say when the shining fires of
the holy ghost had posted in
sign that made the Roman, uh,
rev, Romans, reverend to the
world, it began again okay.
With a illusion therefore
to the Romans as if to uh,
as a kind of idea Rome to
Dante's become an idea,
an idea of universality, you
know, uh, to this kingdom.
Never ever rose who did not believe in
Christ either before or after he was
nailed to the tree but no many Christ,
Christ,
Christ who shall be far less
near to him at the judgment.
Then there's 10 such as, no,
not Christ in such Christians,
the Ethiopians,
Africa is being mentioned.
Check on them when the two companies
are partnered, what can the Persians,
Asia, once again, the three
continents are going to be.
So that divisions of belief now and its
divisions who believe seem to lose or
consistency because you may be
a European and that is immoral.
Alterity within Europe,
it's altered.
It is not just a question of geographic,
uh,
disposition sort of part of the economy.
Someone who is a Persian is other than me.
It is,
but there is in terms of the moral life,
clearly there is an alternative
within Europe. In fact, Dante does,
he starts with a kingdom of Prague lines
18 Alberta by which the Carroll Shelby
made desolate and then to
France then shall be seen.
The misery brought on the second
count. All the countries, by the way,
he seems to know the history of on the
same from the debasement of the currency.
By him,
the shall die from the charge of a bore.
There shall be seeing the pride
that makes Thurston so madness,
the Scott and the Englishman that
neither can keep within his bounds.
Oh,
there is a,
there's a history of violence that
transgresses also boundaries are right and
that can be a violence and I will
give you a little story about that.
It will show the wantonness and
soft living of him, of Spain,
and of people of Bohemia who never,
who never knew worth no salted.
It will show for the cripple of Jerusalem,
his goodness marked with an eye.
What an m. We'll mark the opposite. It
will show the average and cowers of women,
the whole to the island,
the fire,
Sicily, where are Kaiser's and
his long ended his long life.
And to make plain his insignificance,
his records should be in contractions.
So we'll note much and little space and
manifest all should be the foul deeds of
his uncle and his brother.
But who my lineage so illustrious and
two crowns have been dishonored and he'll
Portugal and he over Norway
shall be there known there.
And he of Russia,
Russia meaning a real literary Russia
who to his own hurt has been the calling
of Venice or happy Hungary.
The ironies heavy. Uh,
if she no longer let herself be wronged
and happy Navarre, if she armors,
if with a mountain that surround her and
for earners of this or men should know
that Nicole Asia and Pharma goals that
are meant and complain of their own beast,
which keeps it's place beside the rest.
So the whole of Europe,
this is now the history of Europe in a
way that Dante has given the history of
the empire Roman Empire. But this
is the history of Europe, Eh,
history of distillation and moral,
bitter election.
These are the terms of,
so what is here and what is there?
What is,
what is,
what is within an economy of redemption?
Where is not out of the
economy of redemption?
This is exactly the
question that Dante asks.
And the answer is that we do not know.
We do not know how
this, uh, salvation, uh,
it's going to work hard. No one
can claim, therefore to, uh,
decide, uh, uh,
what exact moral boundaries can exist
between a place and then other, um,
that seems to be, uh, the
idea that a 10%, therefore,
the notion on the one hand,
the idea of boundaries.
And on the other hand there is also
this notion that boundaries can,
uh, are, are political,
but they are not. No.
Can they be thought of as being moral
boundaries? So it distinguishes the two,
the tool, uh, the two issues.
What, what is his, so what is,
is trying to say before I
tried to tell you about this,
let me tell you about a little text.
Has nothing to do with the Middle Ages,
but I'm sure you know the techs.
It's that little story that Geraldo
who is a great Greek historian,
tells this story of, uh, in, uh, uh,
the history's really before the beginning
of the Greeks are getting ready to
invade Egypt,
go into Egypt.
And he really writes a story
to warn them about what, uh,
uh,
the dangers that they might be
surprised by all the dangerous,
wherever you go across boundaries,
that and violate boundaries.
It's really an argument
in favor of boundaries.
And he tells the story of a King,
the king of Egypt,
a cow, the cow, the arrows.
I think his name is who, oh,
was not a very sharp man.
A very, very bright man.
[inaudible] was not a very bright man.
He also had a very beautiful wife and
he was so taken with the beauty of his
wife that he wanted
everybody to know about it,
but he can't tell everybody.
But he tells his advisor and the
advisor who is a very prudent man, says,
sire, Your Majesty. I don't want to, I
believe you don't tell me more about this,
but you got to know,
you've got to hear me because you know,
normally you got to hear me. I want
you to see the naked beauty of my wife,
the young belief.
And I want you to see it because human
beings tend to trust their eyes more than
what they hear more than the ears.
We don't really believe what we
hear is that there may be at power.
We see is directed. We want
to have access to it. The,
the counselor, a very prudent fusses and
sorry, this is really too much trouble.
I can not disobey you,
but you are forcing me to,
to really insist that I
believe you completely.
You can go and telling me about how
beauty, I don't want to say it. No,
I mean a range in this, uh,
he contrives a little plot.
The wife has to go bathing some
in the room next to the bedroom.
He king leaves the door ajar,
open for her to come in the bedroom door.
Um,
and so while she's away,
he allows the counselor to hide
in the shadows of the room.
The little corner.
The queen comes in and
addresses the counselor,
sees her naked and very
quickly, uh, works out,
hoping silently and hoping
not to have been been seen.
The morning after the Queen,
it was a sharp queen.
Calls him into her office and says,
I saw you telling me what we're
doing there so the counselor has no,
no choice but saying,
your majesty,
the king. Your husband asked me to
come in there and the Queen says,
I imagine that that's really what
happened. But uh, at this point,
one of you two is one too much,
too many.
One of you are that you kill the
king or you kill yourself. Yeah.
Idea that I have been ashamed and be
seen a naked but two men is unbearable to
me and the counselor,
that's what I'm sure all of you would do.
He became the cake.
A very simple, uh, and by the way, uh,
her other schools only even saying that,
you know,
he lived a very undistinguished life.
It was not a big deal. I said, well,
he's wording her other visibility,
warning us to understand that there is
always a limit to that have to set up and
protect between what we say me or mine,
I,
and what I say you,
this is the land was a dentist uses the
beginning of Canto 20. They say, ah,
they say I in mind when they mean
we and our, you know, this is,
this is a very thin line that
has to be observed. Uh, uh,
the king of course, just to finish
that little story that king was, was,
was a fool. He had no clue that
he had no sense of, uh, the, the,
the difference between the private
lives and the public needs.
It had no idea that there are things
that you keep to yourself and you don't
share with others as one can
go on complicating the problem.
But the issue is that
he understood limits.
You are going on into
another man's country.
You have to act a safe.
Uh,
you don't have to go too deep into it
and you don't have to try to violate.
It's uh, uh, countries, a
woman's nakedness, meaning they,
the essential sent the private
sense of, uh, of oneself.
I do not know that Dante would really
agree with her auditors in this, uh,
in this, in this cancers. But what he's
been doing is literally setting up,
uh, a needed cultural
difference. Somehow there is a,
that they exist cultural differences and
at the same time allow for the kind of
moral circulation of ideas.
Let me put it in general,
medieval terms to tell you what I
think he has been doing because the,
the argument when he makes this argument,
a man is born on the river of the
Hindus and does not know anything about
Christian faith and baptism dies.
Why should he be them, et cetera.
He has been living, uh,
decorously and rationally.
Why should he be not saved? That's the
question we asked. Well, he's taking on,
there didn't seem to be what
we call in medieval terms,
Appalachian Appalachian
stance and you know,
now I think I have said before,
but let me just repeat this.
Pathogen is an adjective that comes
from the name of a British monk of the,
roughly the time of Santa Gastin,
the fifth century Bellagio's who really
maintain that by the exercise of,
by the true works, through
good works, human beings,
every sec living according
to principles of nature,
human beings can be saved.
It didn't seem almost that Dante's
taking that position to a position,
by the way,
which she probably even held in the
philosophical text called the banquet.
That was one of, it's one of, I
don't, I don't agree with that,
but it seems to be such an emphasis
on the ability of human beings to live
rationally that, uh, the, the, uh,
the demands of grace and
the demands of faith,
uh, somewhat bracketed and, and, and,
and, and a little dim and under is,
I think that they are, are only
that he's talking is a philosopher.
And the issue is this, that Dante here
is asking for the conversation between,
between philosophy and theology within
reason and faith in the sense that he
really understands that philosophy
without theology ends up in a sort of
labyrinth of a tone constructions
and get it may lose the way.
And theology without philosophy
may end up in mere opinion,
which has no validity at all on,
for people who believe in the power,
the power of reason not to connect
it with the previous scandals.
I think that Dante has been
literally extending, uh, this,
this whole, uh, uh,
problem about what, uh, uh,
exile is an exile,
which does not mean, uh,
the random movement, uh,
but always a kind of a,
uh, a sense of the proper
problematical qualities of, uh,
uh, a place in the world. And, uh, uh,
the relationship that we have
with ourselves and our own,
our own ideas. I know that this was such
an attorney to get a little bit that I,
uh, taste taking me away
from the other candles,
but let me just read 21. Uh, and, uh,
the cantors or just went
to turn very briefly.
I don't think that I'm 21 and 22,
uh,
which are candles were Dante meets.
It's the sphere of Saturn,
which as you know, is the heaven of, uh,
it's the heaven of contemplation.
Uh,
the word Saturn, them, the myth
of Saturn is the myth of time,
uh,
devouring everything that it engendered.
That's what you remember the time is
the first cannibal of history eating up.
What it producers, this is, uh, you
know, the minutes that are just taken in.
It's the name seems to come from
the saturation desaturation of time.
And Nancy's coming to,
this is the last planet and it's
also the heaven of astronomy. Uh,
so he's forcing on us the idea
of what contemplation is. Here.
He finds the contemplative and among them
there is the soul of a founder by the
name of Benedict. Uh, the first, uh,
the, the from one of the contemplative,
older came to the word contemplation.
A really implies two things. If
you ask, what is it? Contemplation.
Because there's always a debate as to
where the Dante's a mistake or it's not
realistic. I think that if
there's anything that he has is,
he's a contemplative in
the true sense of the word.
The word contemplation
translates the Greek theory,
which is really the turning of
the mind toward the essentials,
uh, theory or contemplation.
The word comes from,
uh, 10 bloom contemplation, which is,
as you know,
the Latin word for pen for,
of a temple borrows from
the Latin word for temples.
They're the same words, you know, uh,
temple there words for
template in the words for time.
I have the same origin and they both
come from the Greek word called Devon
Minnow. Uh, the Greek word
[inaudible], which means to cut,
to cut Saturday time with a scythe cuts.
Their contemporaries are those who cut
a space of time and privilege it or a
space in place and cut it off from the
flow of history and the flow of a profane
place and make it the, the, the,
the sort of ground for turning their
minds to the consideration of higher
thinks.
This is the poet that Dante is driving.
His going to discuss the degeneracy of a,
of the older,
but I want to really end with you and
I didn't meant to talk about this.
Up Sign will emerge at the end
of Canto 22. Uh, we're done.
Pinole is really has reached the,
the periphery of the planetary
system. Now who will go into, uh,
the stars, the, the, the, the,
the heaven of the six stars. Okay.
We have a little bit of time
so I can go slow here. Uh,
lines canto 22 lines.
Um, uh, let's say 126.
This is Beatrice speaking that word.
So near to the final blessedness Beatrice
began that thou must have denies clear
and keen. Now that's
Dante's. He will, he will,
uh,
deploy this language of visionary leaders
and the language of visual learners.
Visual learners will,
we'll start with the emphasis on clay
purifying Vance and refining one's own,
uh, uh, once hone nice and
once physical eyesight. Uh,
and therefore before you go farther
into it, look down be it is.
It's one of the two, uh, the two
invitations by Beatrice now to turn back,
turn the ice bag and having
a contemplation and Dante
will contemplate so to
speak, the earth not
up. The heavens turned.
And therefore,
uh,
before you go further into to look down
and see how much of the universe I have
already put been beneath my feet
so that with the fullness of joy,
that hearts may present itself to the
triumphal host that comes rejoicing
through this rounded ether with my site.
Dante now is engaged in this
retrospective glance down to the earth.
I returned through every one of the seven
spheres and I saw this globe such as I
smiled earth and it's paltry sum ones.
The perspective is that of a
space, I wouldn't call it infinite
space, but the vast distance of space,
I don't call it infant space because
Dante's notion of the universe is not that
it's infinite down to is the
notion of the universe is uh,
eh bounded but a vast uh,
connect, uh, Vasta a enclave.
It's really like a book.
That's the image that he uses and that
judgment which holds it for least I
approve as best and he has thought is on
the other things may rightly be called
just I saw Latona his daughter,
the moon growing without the shadow for
which are to believe that to be rare
dance. They science aspect
Hyperion, I in Europe,
there and I, so both Maya and
they own a move in the circles.
Many mercury near him
from thence appear to me,
the tempering of jove between
his father and his son.
And from thence they
changes were clear to me,
which they're making their positions.
And those seven showed me what is the
magnitude and what is the speed and the
distance. This Dave, so
we have an astronomy here,
they haven't of astronomy,
but whoever in astronomy,
which is indicated mythically and neuro
only mythically but also through a
process of failure patients is
the daughter of black Latona,
the son of a Hyperion son,
uh, processes affiliation.
So it's really as if the university itself
has followed the logic of generation
of production has been uh,
uh,
producing and reproducing itself.
And then does he go, continues.
Dante goes back to looking at
the earth. Uh, um, I'm sorry.
Another seven showed to me what is the
magnitude and where is the speed and the
distance,
the stations,
the little threshing floor
that makes us so fierce.
All appeared to me from hills to river
mouth while I was willing with the
eternal twins.
Then to the fair eyes,
I turned my eyes again.
I want to draw your attention to line
one 51 where dentists is the little
threshing floor that makes us so fierce.
All appear to me like who all
she far to Pharaoh [inaudible]
chief are looking at that line,
look at it.
Uh,
to me a little hill trigger months while
I was reading with eternal twins. Uh,
Nantum anyways, has, uh, uh,
now that's part of his view of,
uh, of, of, of um, uh, astronomy.
He's given his horoscope
in directory here, the,
this idea of uh, uh, the
twins being the sign,
the which he was born. It doesn't
imply an astrological laps on his path.
It's now that he can be free.
And here's this determined
to the limitations of
astrological determinations.
He can go on alluding to his birth sign,
but I want to draw,
I just want to do the attention
to this whole point about the CI.
We a dentist is that will threshing
floor that makes us so fierce.
It was for all its distance.
And this says this and this,
it can pick and be, um,
this for all the distance,
which is implied by this poetic fiction.
His distance from the earth.
Is He ever wash this pronoun?
She pass us the pronoun
strains to have it both ways.
On the one hand than search distance,
uh,
the claim of a perspective
of eternity on the world.
And, uh, uh, but he does
not. That's the other way.
He does not want to surrender his place
in time and in history like he's part of
us.
So at the end of all this great
gyration through the universe,
Dante again claims every
claims for himself,
a place with us in the world of history,
in the world of time,
the synthesis of the tool,
the claim of eternity and the sense of
contingency of the self in time is the
ultimate goal of the poem.
And the ultimate goal of, uh,
uh, the, the, the journey,
uh, that for Dante will be as
we shall see maybe next week,
the very vision of the incarnation,
the to the idea where this, uh,
this to the structure, the
mutable structure of history
and the process of time.
We'll, uh, we'll come
together. Um, let me, uh,
stop here and see if they are, they
are questions that I would, um,
about some of these issues
that I raised that I would, uh,
I would welcome them please.
The passage by the way,
about, uh, maybe we should,
even the passage where Dante talks
about his old horoscope was given,
uh, a little earlier
line, one 12 of Canto 22,
where the anthesis Oh,
glorious stars,
all light pregnant with mighty power
from which I acknowledge all my genius,
whatever it be, uh, with you
was born and with you hidden he,
that is the father,
which mortal life.
When I first tasted the
Tuscan area and Nafta,
when Greece was granted me
to enter into the high wheel,
that bears around your region was
assigned to me, to you, my soul.
Now size devoutly that is
may gain strength for the
hard task that draws it to,
uh, to itself. This is the, uh, uh,
Dante ballers is the differences
between astronomy and astrology.
But from this point of view,
he belongs fully to his time where
there is no intrinsic. The, we, we,
we think of them as a straw bridges of
superstition and astronomy is the science
that it was not the case,
uh, for, for Dante. But,
um,
yeah,
the, uh, another little details is a, I'm,
I'm introducing the question
of visionary nest now in um,
in cantos with the contemplation.
Uh, let me just mention this,
a initial emerge to give you an idea of
how Dante proceeds the initial image.
I can two 21 of the very beginning of
Canto 21 Dante is in the sphere of Saturn
where the contemplate a contemporary of
his heart. Uh, and he says the ladder,
the ladder of ascent. Um, but
let's, before we get there, uh,
this is the passage already.
My eyes were fixed on the face of
my lady and with them, my mind,
which was withdrawn from every other
thought. And she did not smile.
But when I to smile,
she began to me.
You will become like similar when she
was turned to ashes for my beauty,
which thou has seen kindle more the
higher we climb by the stairs of the
Terminal Palace. He so shining
that if it were not tempered,
they more two powers in it and it's
blazed would be as a branch split by
thunderbolt,
we have risen to the seven splendor which
beneath the rest of the burning lion
race down now mingled with
its power set a mind behind,
denies and make of the mirrors to the
shape which in this metro will appear to t
uh, this is an extraordinary merge
the image of the myth of similar,
the young woman who fell in love with God
that would seem to be,
uh, of course, uh, Eh,
an extraordinary spiritual story of
it tells it has a very carnal story.
She wants to love a Jupiter and
Jupiter will agree to love Semele back
on one condition that she never ask God
to show himself forth for what he is.
She has to accept his,
the guards disguises if variant,
if you wish of what later
will appear with a players.
The idea of arrows and psyche.
You remember the love of the, the
relationship with in mind and love. Uh,
love mate.
That's not one to be seen for what it is.
And always once Simulacra
and a deceptive, uh, uh,
figures to cover its essence. This is
the same thing that he's asking that,
that,
uh,
Dante's recalling and of course what
happens in all of it is that seminar and
love and because of love,
love, impels curiosity. Uh,
she was Jupiter to show himself,
fought for what he is mindless of the
danger that Jupiter had predicted this
would be for, uh, and the danger of
death that would be for her. In fact,
he shows himself and she cannot bear the
extraordinary beauty of the guard and
gets destroyed, turned into ashes.
That's the myth that antiques recalling.
So that the inevitable question for us
is why would Dante recall this story here
at the beginning of the
cantors and contemplation?
And the answer that I
could give you is that, uh,
Dante Dusseau because he's aware
of the dangers of visionary claims.
And this is, look, if you
read the Bible for instance,
you do know that there is a tradition in
the Bible among the Jews to turn their
back,
for instance,
to even the passing of a
what is viewed as whole.
It would be the holy ark or they
cover themselves in because of the,
the, the, the wisdom or the
tradition of not seeing,
never trying to,
to,
to have mix the profane and they say that
all the sense of the danger that would
be for the, the uh, those
who are in the space of the,
of, of the profane space or
what outside of the sanctuary.
Dante is making this abuse resist
telling him that he has to a newer
delimitations of his human nature and
that his human nature that is the trade of
his mortality, a which is that
of seeing through images and, uh,
in, in, in, through obliquities
cannot yet be given up.
He does this as he enters the con,
the heaven of the contemplative who they
themselves were longing and desiring to
say God,
but accepted this longing as the sign
of God's presence and gift to them.
This is an extraordinary passage in
terms of what [inaudible] thinks of
contemplation and clearly the danger
of thinking of contemplation as the
conditions that would allow and bring
about the vision of God. Such a visual,
Dante saying is not going to be
impossible while we are here on earth.
So there's, this is the, the
sort of, the number of, uh, uh,
ambiguities about this problem.
And then we could also mentioned the,
uh,
why Benedict, uh, why benedict here, the,
the figure that appears in Canto
22 as the exemplar. First of all,
he's the founder, as I said,
of the, the, uh, of, of, uh,
the life of contemplation.
But allow for contemplation that appears
is the danger of contemplation because
Dante goes on talking
about the decadence of a,
of the contemplative all
dark, which is by the way, uh,
quite true. And what
that which occasion, uh,
historically the foundation
of the mendicant holders,
those Franciscans and Dominicans who may
already have encountered who want to be
part of the world and roam around
in the world. But the, the,
the danger of the contemplation though,
is that they can bypass and drive a wedge
between the contemplative life and the
active life.
The ideal of benedict has been betrayed
because what he wants is an action and
the life of action,
the life of contemplative prayer.
So that's one of the causes of the
degeneracy that Dante Porsche's.
And with that we enter the world of,
uh,
now we're done to returns.
And this is where we're going to do
next time to what I call basic words.
Uh,
somehow the whole commpass of knowledge,
the whole idea of a geography
and spiritual geography,
the whole idea of how,
of what triggers the writing of a
poem that has been taken care of, uh,
or at least it's Dante seems to have
been facing and delivering to us his
particular understanding of this problems.
Now the question is,
with all of this in mind,
what are the mean?
What is the meaning of the basic words
we use and the basic words we use?
And that's where we're going to talk about
next time are going to be love, hope,
and, and, and, and faith.
But we call the three theological virtues.
And there are basic words because there
is no such a thing as a life without
trust or the difficulties of
the life without trust that can,
there is no possibility
of a life without hope.
And certainly that which remains
the biggest mystery of all.
There's never the possibility of
thinking about a life or without love and
becomes a mystery. It was, he can be
fine. The other two words, he never,
he escapes the responsibility
of defining glove. I see.
It is as if that were really
the biggest mystery, uh,
throughout the divine comedy
and in, uh, in his experience.
So let me see for some questions.
Now.
I have thrown up out of a full time
out of chestnuts on the fire as we say.
So it's a
please
earlier lectures.
It was a physical journey,
um,
and in how we could see that he was,
he emphasized like his weight
in the earth and you know,
smells of things. And now,
now that we're in paradise,
it's more vision and light and color.
And is he trying to characterize God
or God's relation to Earth Somehow by
contracting them?
Uh,
the question is that in the previous
lectures I discussed that I would talk of
hell is the place where
the, the, ah, the smells,
the concrete or particulars of
the earth would be mentioned.
It would be part of Dante's warehouse of,
in,
in the representation of, of
how, now that we're talking,
we're entering the world of paradise,
who been told discussing paradise.
Dante seems to, uh, separate
himself from the aesthetics.
That's the sensual I, uh,
aspects of, of Helen talk more,
which is still central.
They'll callers a lie, uh, uh,
callers and visionary
ness. Ah, right. So, uh,
and then the question becomes,
uh,
it does this mean that Dante is clearly,
clearly finding a distinction between
Earth and heaven? That this is really the,
am I in rephrasing it accurately?
Yes.
Is He, is he tried to, I mean,
because clearly it's not that he's trying
to separate God from physical reality
because what we see and colors
are still very physical. Yes.
Descriptions.
So what is the distinction between them?
Yup. Well, I the, the, uh, the,
the answer would be this,
that in, in, uh, in paradise,
you do have a lot of, uh, what
did we call earthly experiences.
That's the only way he can really,
he could really understand that anything
about, uh, about, uh, about paradise,
uh, their dances, their
songs. You do have,
there are games that they play.
You do have the language of playfulness
in the forms of India in the form of
simulations.
Simulation is a very,
it's a form of game is it's a reduction
of the world tool on seriousness,
right? The Gay, the play, um, in,
in, in, in, in the, in the, in,
in the form of the degradation of the
noble idea of play because play is,
see this things are all very ambivalent,
uh,
that we were dealing with
the same reality, only seen
from different perspective.
And I mentioned play because
paradise is all about play.
It's about playing about, uh, uh,
the dance of the stars, about the
spectacle, the theater, which he just,
Dante is just seeing a little
log performance put out for him.
Can you imagine that? Then
some of the stars that go
on, it's, it's like seeing a,
the spectacle of the, of the
Olympics. Uh, in China. You know,
the goal with distribution of
shapes and forms that is play, uh,
it's a statics. So there is no
difference there between, uh, uh,
between the tool. Uh, I
don't see a difference.
Of course that has nothing to do.
Whatever he's seeing in
paradise has really nothing
to do with the understanding
of the divinity. I am not
even, I haven't decided yet,
not for any reason that because they
may not really be time and that would,
I could, I wouldn't, I wouldn't be a,
wouldn't be doing justice to
the difficulty of the problem.
I haven't decided whether
to discuss the whole,
the cosmology of paradise of the,
of the,
of the universe that appears in Canto 29
of paradise where Dante goes on talking
about tool universities for instance.
So there is the physical universe
that somehow he has traversed only to
understand that when he goes there,
there is another universe which is
completely spiritual and it's not the
platonic idea of an inverted,
you know,
played with this idea of an inverted
cosmos. We are in the world,
which is really the projection. Yeah.
Projection and unreal projections.
It's projection meaning meaning
a shadow of, of the real costs.
It's not really that there are two
adjacent cosmos, both little real,
and that's the one where we live
in where we don't live beyond that.
Beyond that is a real, a
speck of sand. He says,
as a speck of sand you,
there is a light that clearly is the
right from which hole or creation,
uh,
emanates.
So God remains forever a transcendence.
Ah,
what Dante does see at the end, this
is his image, uh, in his own image,
in the plural our emerge,
which to me implies the idea that
we as Christians read the,
the whole notion of genesis is that in a,
since we are shaped in God's image,
there is our imaging God.
Okay. There is a human component
in God. So that's how he sees.
He sees maybe the incarnation,
but it's all of that is all
wrapped in a kind of extraordinary,
uh, and deliberate fogginess
of a overrepresentation.
Um, but the, the paradise
that he describes,
it is not the same that they're proud
of us of central delights of the Koran,
for instance. Uh, but there's
a lot of gay men play and,
and as the stars,
the arm motors,
this scores of paradise engages in
involves, even though the stars,
they're gone. When you, it,
this is literally the whole cosmos is
involved in this extraordinary dance of
love. The keeps it together, makes
it go here as opposed to say,
Lou Cliche,
this idea of an archaic universe
forever on the verge of,
of falling apart, that the,
this is the real models of,
of the cosmos.
You know,
let's call it Lucretia's and Virgil and
the way epicureans Epicurus and Plato,
you know, this is a
Danton the, and the heavy,
the heavy traditional is, it's very
heavy, traditional materialism.
The spiritual tradition is very small
in comparison to the heaviness of a,
of a,
of the physical or the scholars of
physics who want to see the cosmos in
physical terms but not the opposes it.
Then somehow he finds a kind of
that that's what the universe,
that's what keeps the universe together
is really love and that's where we going
to find out that uh, that we'll
read the rest. I don't know.
I thought questions.
Please be interest is warning Dante not
to look directly at her face because he
might become like simile
and just turned to ashes.
Do you think Dante is trying to allude
back to Medusa and the danger of just
looking directly into the
thesis of something so
powerful and being reduced to,
you know, something that isn't human
like, oh no, I was, I was reading down,
she said set that in mind behind nine
eyes and makeup and mirrors to the shape
in which, uh, which in this
mirror will appear to the SF.
Like the mirror is sort of,
the mirror is less like the eyes,
like the intermediary,
just like the shield was the
intermediary for looking at the Medusa.
Very good question. I think
just record the question. Uh,
the imager of Beatrice's Samela ah,
whose smile could potentially
destroy the lover,
the, the, the pilgrim who
were to look looker, her face.
Uh, the question is, does, is
that supposed to be a salt of,
let's call it poly Nordic variant
or version of the scene of Medusa?
Uh, in a, in federal nine,
uh, who threatened also the,
in that case, the pilgrim, uh, with, uh,
pacification with the turning
into stone intellect would, uh,
would petrify that's really
the, the allegory. Uh,
and they are of course in the Canto
of Medusa, ah, there was always,
always the shield, the shield of
poetry, right. The Shield will pursues,
uh, uh, and the answer is yes. Absolutely.
This is exactly what is happening.
I think that this is a, yeah. If you're
thinking is, I think you are of writing,
uh, about, uh, are you
thinking of writing? No.
Uh, about Medusa? No,
I haven't decided yet.
Okay. Well, but if you think you'll be
right, I think a paper about the middles,
I think that you are absolutely you would
and the two scenes you'd be absolutely
correct. The story of Medusa
is what is interesting.
This sort of Medusa is the story of a,
we could view it.
We view that as you remember the
temptation of it looking at the past,
a way of or fuels a turning down
to cast himself as all fuse office.
You know who is told not to look back
and yet or few stands for assault of
impatience. A kind of a
skepticism about the injunction.
The fear that you read is it
may not really be following him.
He turns and losers. Some modern
mythology offers even see that low carb.
I'm thinking about a man by no brunch
roses. He really wanted to lose.
You read the sea and
because he saw this way,
he would write poetry so of Porridge
or can become the perpetual voice of
absence, etc. It doesn't not go that far,
but it's clear that it's tied to
a pointing experience of his own.
The, the, the interesting thing
about what you are saying, uh,
we could go into that may in, in
conversation, uh, laser because it's,
it would take me too far.
It's that this enigmatic, the,
the double phase of Beatrice comes
to the fore here that she has,
you know,
uh,
she was confronting this Irene
and threatens against the siren.
And now she also appears as the,
uh,
the sorcery and in danger of beauty,
beauty.
That is that which was the language
here is beauty. Beauty, which can,
which we,
we hunger after.
And yet it's that which can
destroy us. And, and, and, and,
and this seems to me to be, uh,
I, I put that in the, in the,
in the consciousness
of the Dantes, uh, uh,
the contemporary thieves
that Dante represents,
this doubleness that you wrong to
see. And yet you may not have to, you,
you better, you are better off
than not seeing. But it's true.
That appears also with the ambiguity
of beauty and the beauty of Beatrice.
That's, that would be true. Yes.
So if, so, if the mirror is sort of
like intermediary, just like the shield.
Like, what role does, um, vision
and the eyes play in, in, in,
in mediating between what
you see in the world and,
and in the mind that it protects?
Well, Dante, we'll law is no slowly, uh,
slowly preparing for this final vision.
And this is going to have
intermediate stages. Uh,
when he will see at the end he will see a,
not God,
he will see his own image
within the beatific vision.
This is how far he will go.
Not only that, he will go, oh,
also there in the clips of the,
in that I have memory, you know,
memory is thought of as being the, in
the eye of the imagination. That's the,
the classical d, uh, uh, the
script definition of a, of memory.
And that too will be completely clips.
He will forget.
So that at the end of all this experience,
we are ending up with a
forgetfulness, uh, with,
with a full from that vision.
I don't know that I'm answering exactly
your question, but I don't know that, uh,
I haven't understood which really want
to know, uh, which really asking. So
I guess I'm just asking more about the
role of vision, like it makes visualness.
Okay. Yeah. Just like it is the,
I suppose to be an intermediary or,
or protection of,
of the mind and what you think
the I, the, the, the,
what is the eye is the intermediary
or the, Oh, an extension of the mind.
That's really what it,
what the I is by the visual he will have,
is not going to be a physical vision.
It can not be a physical vision.
This could be a spiritual vision. And
so there are the limitations of the sea.
That's, let me leave that, that I'm
going to get that. Okay. Thank you.
See you next time.